all right so one question I get asked a
lot from job Seekers is which Cloud
platform should I focus my learning on
is it better to learn AWS Azure or
Google Cloud now with the three big
players battling it out for market share
it can be hard to figure out which one
to learn but the truth is there isn't
really a right answer each platform has
its own strengths and weaknesses and at
the end of the day it really depends on
your own goals and what you want to
achieve which is why in this video I'll
be comparing the three major cloud
computing platforms so that you can
decide for yourself which one to learn I
mean I'm obviously ly very biased and
love AWS because I previously worked
there as a Solutions architect for 2
years but to make sure we're covering
all our bases here let's take a look at
these five factors so the first one is
market demand then job opportunities
ecosystem support unique features and
learning resources before we dive in
please make sure you give this video a
like And subscribe to this channel to
stay updated with Cloud Learning tips
all right let's get into it so first
things first let's talk about market
demand in today's world we've all seen
that more and more businesses are
turning to the to the cloud for the
Computing needs which of course has
resulted in a huge surge in demand for
professionals with Cloud skills AWS
Azure and Google Cloud all three have a
strong presence in the cloud computing
Market but AWS Still Remains The Leader
with 30% market share this means that
there's a high demand for people with
AWS skills making it a great choice for
job Seekers aure comes in second with
around 22% market share and Google cloud
is next with about 9% even though these
two platforms are smaller than AWS they
are growing very fast so I still
recommend and learning them if you're
interested in working for a particular
company you can also do some research to
see what cloud platform they use for
example Netflix uses AWS Spotify uses
Google cloud and Coca-Cola is an
Enterprise customer of azure now
speaking of companies let's talk about
the job opportunities within each
platform as I mentioned earlier AWS has
the highest market demand meaning that
there's a lot of jobs available in fact
after doing a quick search I found that
there's over 150,000 jobs currently
listed on LinkedIn that require AWS
skills Azure and Google Cloud also have
a large number of job opportunities with
50,000 and 20,000 jobs listed for each
one my advice is to take a look at the
job opportunities in your local area to
see which Cloud platform is highest in
demand for example if there's a lot of
azure job openings where you live then
it might be a good idea to learn that
there's also a growing demand for cloud
engineers and solutions Architects that
specialize in more than one platform
this means that if you have skills in
two clouds for example both AWS and
Azure it could make you a better fit for
companies that have a m Cloud setup but
then again I wouldn't worry too much
about that as a beginner since it's
better to have a strong understanding of
one Cloud rather than a basic knowledge
in all of them another Trend in the job
market is the rise of remote work and
freelancing opportunities with the
global scale of cloud services companies
are now more open to hiring remote
workers and Freelancers to work on their
projects this means that you may not
have to live in a specific location to
secure a high paying job so yeah
something else for you to keep in mind
another factor to consider when choosing
a cloud platform is the ecosystem and
Community Support what I mean by this is
the amount of guidance and support from
other users or experts within the cloud
Community AWS has a very strong
ecosystem there's a wide range of
resources available from extensive
documentation to workshops and free
online courses they also have large
communities of developers Architects and
other professionals who are willing to
share their knowledge this can be done
through forums meetups or even
conferences like AWS reinvent Asha also
has a pretty good support network and
offers similar resources ources their
ecosystem seems to be about the same
size as AWS and they have cool
communities like Azure Tech groups
Google cloud has a smaller Community
from what I've seen but they're quickly
building up their resources and
ecosystems this includes documentation
tutorials conferences and meetup groups
and so if you're looking for a cloud
provider with a wellestablished
ecosystem and Community I would
recommend either AWS or Azure before we
move on to the next factor to consider
I'd like to introduce you to data Stacks
now if you haven't heard of data Stacks
there are compan that provides real-time
Vector data tools that generative AI
apps need their product astrab is a
great Vector database for building
production level AI applications on
real-time data with astrab you get up to
18% more relevant Vector search results
eight times to 15 times higher
throughput and can request responses up
to 12 times faster not to mention the
database as a service integrates
seamlessly with Azure AWS and gcp and
can run on all of those clouds at the
same time and so if you're looking for a
highly performant efficient database
server to handle Vector non vector and
concurrent streaming data I would
recommend choosing astrab I'll leave a
link to it in the description below
thank you data stacks for sponsoring
this video okay another important factor
to consider is the unique features and
services offered by each cloud provider
let's dive into each one to see what
sets them apart AWS is known for its
incredibly extensive list of services
there's over 200 fully featured services
available and this includes products
like Amazon ec2 for compute S3 for
storage and Amazon RDS for databases
what also sets AWS apart is the
specialized services for certain use
cases for example Amazon recognition is
a powerful tool they have for image and
video analysis Azure also has a large
number of products and services with
over 200 available some cool Services
they have include Azure cognitive
services for AI and machine learning
Azure functions for event driven
Computing and Azure devops for cicd
pipeline operations one big advantage of
using Azure is the integration they have
with Microsoft products like Office 365
this means that if a company is already
using Microsoft tools they might choose
to go with Azure Google Cloud may not
have as many services as AWS or Azure
but they do offer some pretty unique
ones for example Google big query is a
great data warehousing and analytics
solution I personally also find that the
Google Cloud interface is really nice
and userfriendly making it easy to
navigate around the final factor to
consider when choosing between AWS Azure
and Google cloud is the availability of
learning resources and training programs
sometimes I hear people asking what is
the easiest Cloud to learn but the truth
is none of them are easy no matter what
platform you end up choosing there'll
always be a learning curve involved I
wouldn't worry too much about this final
Factor because all through programs have
some pretty good free resources to help
you get started for example AWS has AWS
skill Builder Azure has Microsoft learn
and Google cloud has the Google Cloud
skills boost as long as you're willing
to invest time into learning the
fundamentals you can become proficient
in any of these three Cloud platforms
all right so this brings us to the end
of the video I hope now you have a
better understanding of which Cloud
platform to learn if you're interested
in starting your Cloud Learning Journey
this year make sure you subscribe to the
channel and check out my other videos
for more Cloud Learning tips thanks for
watching and I'll see you soon bye for
now